Okay.
Last lecture of the semester,
we're going to talk about the big question.
How did this little group of Jews following a profit and apocalyptic prophet
around Galilee who is then executed,
uh,
shortly thereafter in Jerusalem become what we now call a major world religion?
How did that happen?
Because the whole first hundred years we've talked about in this class of what
we now call Christianity,
of course,
it's not even called Christianity until the letters of Ignatius.
There was no term Christianity and the Bible itself,
and as I've said,
the Apostle Paul certainly did not use the term Christian.
He probably would have rejected it because that would imply that he was doing
something else besides just bringing the gentiles into Israel.
He thought he was continuing Israel,
not making another religion.
So how did this ragtag bunch of people following Jesus and then these different
house churches become what's called now a major world religion.
We'll talk a bit about that today and then I'm going to talk in the class with a
little bit of stuff on a theory of interpretation that we've hit on over the
semester.
I should also remind you that,
um,
at the end of the class will be passing out the instructions for your final
exams.
I'll leave about 10 minutes or so of time for us to talk about that.
So you'll have plenty of time to ask questions about the final exam once you get
the instructions.
And finally,
since this is your last chance,
I'll be sure and stick up your hand if you want to ask a question or make a
comment.
This is the time if you want to throw things and be a rebel against the course,
this is probably the best time to do it.
Your last chance.
So ask any questions you want also about any of these topics and we'll talk
about that
from the teachings of Jesus to the Gospel about Jesus.
That's one of the first things that happens.
We've already seen that going on the historical Jesus.
And if you really are,
have not had enough of this and you want to take a historical Jesus course,
I'm going to be teaching a seminar for undergraduates on the historical Jesus in
the fall,
uh,
open to anybody.
And we'll have a full semester to,
to deal with these problems with the historical Jesus in a seminar setting that
hits the historical Jesus did not talk about himself as the Christ.
We just don't have them doing that except from the gospel of John.
It may well have been that he thought he was the messiah or that he thought he
was preceding the Messiah Messiah.
Somebody must have thought that he was a messianic figure because that's what
the Romans executed in for.
So either he may have thought he was the messiah,
or some of his disciples may have hoped that he was my messiah,
uh,
but he didn't go around preaching about himself.
The topic that Jesus talks about the most in the synoptic gospels is actually
the Kingdom of God.
This thing that was expected to happen in the future.
So the historical Jesus first is,
is talking about some gospel that it's a,
it's good news,
but it's about this coming kingdom of God that's gonna be when God's going to
break in.
But very quickly after his death,
uh,
as we see already by the letters of Paul,
the earliest material in the New Testament,
the gospel of Jesus,
the Gospel,
the good news he proclaimed became the gospel about Jesus.
In other words,
the good news was who was this man and what does that mean for us?
So that's the first major change that happens in early Christianity on the way
to becoming Christianity.
And there you've seen the growth of the Pauline churches.
So the first thing that happens is it moves out of Palestine and it moves
through up the Greek speaking world in the West.
And very early,
we don't know by whom that a church,
a church was planted in Rome because it's already there.
By the time Paul writes to the Romans has been there for four years,
we've seen how there's a diversity of early Christian groups.
And in fact,
your final exam will require you with you choose,
you'll choose one of two questions.
It will cry you to address this issue that we've been hitting on all semester
long about how diverse this early movement was.
What did it,
what did different groups look like?
We've also talked the last lecture about how did some of the institutions of the
church start gradually being developed,
such as having a bishop,
having priests,
having deacons,
uh,
and then the establishment of the Lord's supper as a piece of liturgy and ritual
that becomes celebrated throughout these different groups.
The practice of baptism being pretty much universally practiced by these groups
very quickly.
We also have seen,
uh,
the part of the beginning of the rise of Christian scripture.
We,
we've not gotten to the cannon in this course,
that actual development of cannabis because that doesn't happen until the
fourth,
fifth,
and sixth centuries when the list of these books that become the New Testament
Canon become more solidified.
But we've seen the beginnings of this,
right?
We've seen how a different gospel writers were used,
other gospels,
we've seen how the writer of Second Peter will talk about Paul's letters as
scripture.
So we've seen a collection of Paul's letters coming about and we've seen the
gospels coming about as a collection in the second century.
And then one of the major things we've seen the beginnings of that will become
more and more important for the nature of Christianity later is its separation
from Judaism.
As I've repeated several times in this course,
the earliest people who followed Jesus never thought they were starting a new
religion.
They thought they were simply continuing the right behavior of Judaism and Paul
himself thought he was continuing.
Judaism is just,
he thought that he was bringing non Jews into it in an in a fairly new way.
But we've seen the beginnings of how in the letter to the,
to the Hebrews who seen the letter,
the sermon end with the author making this weird statement about let us go
outside the camp.
As Jesus was executed outside the city of Jerusalem and the sacrifices were done
in exodus outside of the camp.
So we as now followers of Jesus,
we should go outside the camp sounding like he's meaning we're going to leave
Judaism.
We have announced superior liturgy in the second century.
This separation of the church from the synagogue will start becoming clear in
certain places.
And finally,
what you'll end up with after the fourth,
fifth and sixth century is a Christian Church that's not Jewish and rabbinic
Judaism that comes to look more like what Judaism has looked,
uh,
since that time,
even different from the Judaism as it was in the time of Jesus.
The second century therefore sees some important changes.
First.
As I've said,
Christianity is still remarkably diverse even in the second century and it does
grow.
How quickly it grows numerically is really impossible to say.
We don't have the kind of demographic data to know how much growth,
how much numerical growth there was in the Christian Church in the second
century,
but we can obviously tell it's happening in different places by,
if nothing more,
see increase in lieu written literature that comes about in different
geographical locations during the second century.
Connections among these different groups also started growing.
As I've,
as I've tried to make clear,
we don't really have any reason to believe that the churches that Paul founded
where that closely connected to say other churches that may have existed in
Syria or in Egypt or in Italy.
Paul did want his churches to remain closely connected to the church in
Jerusalem.
And that's precisely why he started this collection.
Uh,
among the gentiles.
Predominantly gentile churches have money to give to the poor,
our church in Jerusalem.
So Paul had this already,
was starting this connection and he's writing letters back and forth.
And we've seen already that other churches seem to be writing letters back and
forth.
These connections start coming a bit more networked in the second century.
Also,
we've also seen how Christian churches start in the second century imitating
Roman political and social structures.
They start imitating the Roman household and their government,
which is having the monarchical bishop,
the one ruling bishop over a town area.
Oh yeah.
We call it the monarchical bishop because the bishop becomes like a king,
a monarch,
uh,
the single bishop over a town.
So that starts happening in more places in the second century.
We've already seen it written letters of Ignatius.
It becomes a lot more prevalent by the time you get to the end of the second
century,
Jewish Christianity starts dying out,
uh,
in the second century.
We do have some Jews who follow Jesus,
they take Jesus to be the Messiah.
Some of them don't seem to believe that Jesus is divine.
They just,
they take them to be a great profit and we maybe even the Messiah,
but not,
that doesn't make him God necessarily.
Uh,
and these Jewish churches are still there in the second century.
We gradually see them become less and less,
uh,
visible,
after the second century.
But we've already seen some other things in the second century that are going
on.
I've talked in the class about gnosticism.
Yeah.
So the Gnostics,
oh,
well they didn't,
there was no church of the gnostics.
There was not a movement that had a sign and a website somewhere that said
gnosticism.
But we use the term as an umbrella term for Christians who held on to certain
kinds of mythological views about genesis and angels and the creation and
different divine figures.
So that's one thing that becomes,
um,
more visible.
In fact,
we believe that most of the texts that come that we find in the non commodity
library,
we know that the library itself,
things have been written in the fourth century,
the actual text.
But we believe that a lot of those texts were written originally in Greek in the
second century.
And then they were translated into most,
mostly Coptic by the fourth century.
So,
but they,
these,
this literature that modern scholars place under the bigger rubric of
Gnosticism,
it starts being written in the second century with elaborate mythologies with
different layers of heaven's,
with different angels are beings a ruling those different layers and different
mythologies about creation and how,
how the creative world came to be.
There is also a very important figure that some people will call gnostic a
gnostic.
But,
uh,
we now cannot tune.
Okay.
Valentine's Day was a Christian scholar who lived in Rome in the middle of the
second century and he gathered around him,
uh,
other Christians and they indulged in sort of a very philosophical way of
thinking about Christianity and the Gospel.
They look gnostic in some ways,
but they don't seem to have a belief in to God's necessarily that,
that,
uh,
other gnostic groups do.
So Valentine is though represents another kind of Christianity that becomes very
visible in the second century.
And it remains important for a couple of centuries after that until all these
kinds of Christianity or declared heretical later in the fourth,
fifth and sixth centuries.
And they're run underground.
But Valentine,
this is a major figure because you can see him [inaudible] he's a highly
educated,
uh,
we don't know a whole lot about him historically biographically but you can just
tell from pieces of the history that he must've been a highly educated,
philosophically educated individual who is trying to do,
to raise the mythologies that he found in genesis and in the Bible to a level of
higher philosophical,
platonic special,
a speculation.
So that becomes very visible.
We've already talked also about Marcien
and I've said that a lot of scholars take it,
that when Marcia and came up with his own Canon of the New Testament,
his list of New Testament,
which included the gospel of Luke,
which he edited to take out all the Jewish stuff in it,
the thought was shouldn't be there.
And they'll make the letters of Paul,
which he also edited.
And just those,
that list of things was his sort of New Testament,
his Christian Canon,
any throughout the Hebrew Bible,
the Old Testament,
because that was too Jewish.
So Marcy and also then is being kicked out of the church in Rome and being
declared a heretic in the second century.
But he founds churches that exist then for a couple of centuries after his
death.
Uh,
and especially in the eastern part of the empire.
So these are all different of Christianity that are really boiling up,
uh,
in the second century as church churches are trying to figure out what does it
mean to be Christian but not necessarily Jewish anymore.
And that one of the other figures that we haven't talked about is mindfulness.
Okay.
This was a prophet who went around the clean declaring that he had a special
gift of the Holy Spirit,
maybe that he was the Holy Spirit.
There were two women who also follow them and they all claimed to have prophetic
gifts and to be able to uh,
speak,
have the Holy Spirit and God speak directly through them.
They developed quite a following.
They were very aesthetic,
very strict.
So they,
for bad marriage and these sorts of things.
And so they,
they were practicing a certain kind of early asceticism and monasticism,
but with this very,
uh,
um,
strong prophetic stream of it.
Also,
they were very active in the second century also.
And then people like,
uh,
Agustine would later have to sort of fight with these people.
You also have in the second century,
the first people that we really can say are Christian philosophers.
These are,
you could say that Paul had a rhetorical education and every once in awhile you
can see stuff in Paul's letters that looks a bit like what you'll see in say,
philosophy.
Stoicism perhaps.
Uh,
there's a friend of mine trials Engberg Peterson,
a professor at University of Copenhagen in Denmark has written a lot trying to
prove that Paul's ideas are heavily stoic,
uh,
and probably deeply influenced by stoicism itself.
Most of us don't buy that,
but we think that you might see traces of stoicism in Paul's writing.
You might say these,
you see traces of Platonism in say the letter of the Hebrews are in the gospel
of John,
but you don't find any new testament riding that looks like it would have come
out of a real philosophical school.
It doesn't have that a high level of philosophical speculation or knowledge that
we have in the second century.
We do have though some,
some individuals arising who style themselves as Christian philosophers and they
style Christianity as itself a philosophy.
And one of the most famous is Justin martyr.
Okay.
Martyr of course is not as nice.
His last name.
It's not like Justin h martyr martyr is his nickname because he was martyred
around the year one 50 in Rome.
Justin claims,
uh,
and we have several writings of him that survive as along with an account of his
martyrdom.
Uh,
Justin claims that he shopped around when he was a young man to all the
different philosophies and he couldn't find any that really satisfied him until
he found this Christian teacher and he attached himself to that Christian
teacher and that teacher introduced him to the philosophy of Christianity.
So you have a person who,
he goes around in robes,
he grows his beard long,
he carries scrolls around tomorrow so he can look like a philosopher at his
trial when he's being condemned.
He defends himself as a philosopher,
like philosophers had,
had to defend themselves against Roman emperors,
uh,
often in the first,
for centuries.
So Justin martyr is one of the first truly sort of philosophical Christian,
uh,
another,
uh huh
that exist in a little bit later.
This is Clement of Alexandria.
He was,
uh,
probably head of a catechetical school,
a Christian school in Alexandria in Egypt.
He wrote toward the end of the second century.
So around the year 200 is when he's riding.
And Clement also clearly has a very good philosophical education.
His writing is,
is excellent.
He,
uh,
he tries to make Christianity,
for example,
he,
he downplays apocalyptic kinds of stuff in Christianity because he knows that
that doesn't look very philosophical.
He downplays the incidents on poverty and they that there are lots of parts of
the new testament's would basically teach that if you're rich,
you won't go to heaven.
Remember how the letter of James Basically seems to condemn rich people just out
of hand,
not just rich people for being,
uh,
when they're evil and not using their money batty,
but just by being rich itself,
you're condemned in some early Christian documents.
Clement rocks against that kind of stuff.
He,
he,
he writes stuff showing how you can be a rich person and enjoy nice things and
still be a Christian.
So he's riding at at the end of the second century,
again,
making Christianity into something that looks much more like a philosophy.
So these things are going on in the second century and that's going to change
Christianity to a great extent because what becomes traditional Orthodox
Christianity is heavily influenced by philosophy,
especially by the Platonism that's around in late antiquity.
The very notion for example,
of the immortality of the soul that you're getting a lot of popular
Christianity,
it comes from Platonism more than it does from anything in the New Testament.
The other development that's going on at this time that will become very
important is martyrdom.
I've talked about that last time.
And of course Justin martyr is one of the examples of this.
So there's no,
there's no general empire wide persecution of Christians in the second century,
but you do have sporadic persecutions arising against Christians in certain
areas.
So in Rome at certain times you all have certain people martyred,
usually leaders or bishops or uh,
people like Justin martyr who are a key figures martyr.
Then therefore starts developing its own ideology and its own theology in the
second century,
which will become very important for later monasticism and way Christian becomes
in the Middle Ages.
You have this idea I talked about last time,
that martyrs or especially close to God,
martyrs go straight to heaven.
They don't pass.
They don't have to,
you know,
uh,
go to Paris to paradise or any place else.
First they go straight to heaven on being killed.
Um,
confessors that is,
people are condemned to Margaret and,
but not martyred.
Uh,
also become especially important as figures who are considered to be closer to
God.
These attacks on Christianity and the way Christians respond to it.
With this sort of marshal almost warlike ideology of martyrdom,
the martyr becomes a soldier in the army of God in the way it's depicted in the
second century.
And this is even up by enemies of Christianity.
So salsas,
the very famous,
um,
no,
Galen,
I mean the,
a very famous doctor.
Okay.
There is a Celsus I'll mention two gallons,
the most famous medical writer of antiquity,
and he's,
he's tons and tons of his medical medical writings.
Still survive.
And it takes forever to read through them,
even in an English translation,
much less than Greek.
And now an Arabic translation that a lot of them surviving.
Galen actually mentions Jews and Christians a few places in his writings.
And one of the things he says that he thinks Christians are stupid.
He thinks they're crazy because they believe in a god who gets angry.
God doesn't get angry.
That goes against the very definition of God.
So he believes that Christians are superstitious,
uneducated.
He thinks that it probably only could succeed with the gullible,
but he's still admires Christians because of the way they faced death.
So even Christians enemies recognize that they had a certain bravery and courage
and being totally willing to face death.
Celsus was as contemporary also living in the middle of the second century.
He wrote against Christianity,
also wrote against Christians.
And he will admit though that they seem to have a certain better bright,
but he just says there foolhardy and being willing to throw themselves on a
sword,
uh,
the way they do and throw themselves to the beast as we've Seen Ignatius,
do in his letters.
Let the bees come to me.
So Celsus and Galen Admire Christians for the courage and the almost military
discipline they have,
even though they despise them for being,
they believe gullible,
superstitious bumpkins.
So you have for the first time,
the second century also then educated non Christians taking notice of the
movement and writing about it and having an idea about it.
And then in response to this kind of thing,
you had the beginning of apologists.
People like Justin martyr himself who wrote an apology for Christianity against
its detractors,
either against the governmental type detractors who said it was a seditious
because it wasn't loyal enough to the emperor or philosophical detractors who
said it was superstition.
And Celsus famously said,
the only people,
these people can convince our old women and slaves and kids know,
you know,
educated band would fall for all this bunk.
But you have Christian apologists,
therefore riding apologies in the second century trying to defend Christianity
against these attacks.
So all of that's already in the second century,
100 years after Jesus is d is turning this little Palestinian movement into
something that is going to start looking more recognizable to us.
But it still takes a long time.
In the third century,
you have developments that are very important.
You have the real rise of monasticism.
Now all the way from the beginning of Christianity,
we've seen that some Christians practiced asceticism and you know that word
asceticism just comes from the Greek word exercise,
but it's come to mean any sort of self discipline for a higher good.
The avoidance of sex,
the avoidance of of food as much as possible.
The avoidance of wine,
drinking only water.
So different groups in the ancient water,
including an ancient world,
including some Jewish groups will be called,
for example,
water drinkers because they will avoid wine out of this.
It's not because they felt like these things were in themselves sinful.
It's that they were using these deprivations of pleasures in order to train the
body and train the soul.
Again,
they were borrowing from Roman military imagery in military audiology.
So Antony,
uh,
Saint Anthony becomes famous.
He's not necessarily the people.
He gets the reputation later for being the first one to go out in the desert and
live totally by himself and discipline his body.
And he gets attacked by demons all of the time.
Demons are always going out to the desert to find him and disguising themselves
as young,
lovely girls or boys and,
and trying to seduce Anthony.
And so he has to fight these demons all alone out in the desert in the middle of
the night.
But he does how you,
how do you fight demons in the like that will you Buffet's your body,
you Buffett,
your soul,
you make your will strong.
And how you do that will you avoid sex?
You avoid desire.
You avoid,
uh,
rich food.
Do you avoid wine?
So strength training the body and training the will like a soldier or an
athlete,
they use both these they athletic imagery and soldier imagery to,
to describe the training.
This all becomes a highly elaborated a ideology and theology starting in the,
in the third century.
And so you have not only groups of monks and sometimes nuns living together,
that's one kind of,
um,
uh,
monasticism we called [inaudible] our CMO bidic or are Koinonia monasticism that
his monks or nuns living,
not monks and nuns living together,
although that seldom happened,
but sometimes did,
but usually monks living together or nuns living together.
And then you have with this movement,
like I said,
with Antony of,
uh,
some monks going off into the desert and living alone and that sort of thing.
So you have both these forms of monasticism starting to develop in the third
century.
This will become hugely important.
As you know,
for Christianity all the way through the Middle Ages,
you couldn't have Europe.
As we think about Europe,
you couldn't have had the learning,
the vast learning and the texts and,
and the classical stuff,
the all the classical texts,
the passing on of literature and Philosophy from antiquity.
You could've had any of that without monasticism through the Middle Ages that
begins.
See in the third century when you have these movements really taking off and
they become hugely important and hugely popular for people.
You also have in the third century,
the first really empower wide persecution of the church and attempt to actually
destroy it and get people to deconvert and to denounce Christianity and a
sacrifice to the emperor.
And this happens with,
uh,
the empire,
the emperor decis.
So we call this the DCN or desean up persecution.
It happens around the time you're one to 50.
So right in the middle of the third century.
And this is the first time that there is an empire wide attempt to suppress the
Christian Church.
Also in the third century,
you have one of the most brilliant and famous it Christian scholars of,
uh,
all of history actually,
origin
origin was later considered to be a heretic.
Um,
for some of the teachings that he came up with about,
for example,
he taught that even Satan could be converted.
In the end,
he,
he believed that all created,
created beings would be brought back up somehow and to God in the end.
This,
and he had views about the nature of a,
of God and the nature of human beings that later would be deeply suspected of
being not quite orthodox enough.
In his own day,
though in the third century,
he was completely orthodox.
Uh,
he had actually been trained,
uh,
and probably the catechetical school in Alexandria that I mentioned before,
that Clement,
uh,
probably headed up.
He started his own school then in Palestine and that's where he spent the rest
of his life in Palestine.
Origin was a great biblical commentator.
He was the first one,
for example,
who took all the different versions of the Greek,
of the Old Testament.
For example,
the Hebrew of it,
the Septuagint,
which was the most famous Greek translation,
but then parts of other Greek translates like by Theodocia or Aquilla.
And he,
he would put these in parallel columns.
And this was a remarkable sort of technology for studying the Bible to be able
to have all these things in parallel columns to be able to compare side by side.
He did that sort of thing.
It's called the Hexapla because it had six columns of the Old Testament.
He wrote reams and reams of,
of commentaries on different books of the Bible,
most of which don't survive.
But,
uh,
we do have quite a bit of it and origin practiced this a way of interpreting
scripture.
I illustrated for you from the medieval period that scripture always has more
than one level of meaning.
In fact,
you remember,
you read some of origin's commentary when you read that chapter from my book
pedagogy of the Bible.
So origin represents in the third century,
um,
a new,
very,
very strong arise in the level of Christian Biblical scholarship.
He's also very philosophically educated.
So he's a part of that tune.
So the,
the tradition of commentary and high level of Christian scholarship also becomes
much more visible in the third century than it had been before,
especially to people like origin.
The fourth century then brings us to basically where I'm going to stop for a
much detail because it's in the fourth century that you have the triumph of
Constantine as the sole.
He beats all the other rivals to the throne,
the,
the empire,
the Roman Empire.
But by this time,
by the year 300 had been divided up into two different basic empires,
the west and the east.
And there was an emperor emperor for each one.
And then there was also a Caesar for each one.
So there were four rulers who ruled the Roman Empire in the year 300,
a two emperors,
one of the West,
and one of the east and two seasons,
one of the West and one east Constantine went to war with w uh,
the other guy on the other side and t one,
he was actually in the West in the beginning.
He won,
he,
you reunited the Empire East and West.
He built his new Rome.
He did.
He didn't take Rome anymore as the capital.
He moved the capital to Constantinople named after him.
Of course,
the city of Constantine or what we call Istanbul,
our Byzantium was,
is it's a ancient name also.
So this is when,
this is basically where we start talking about the beginning of Byzantine
Christianity because it's named after the town Byzantium or Constantinople or
Istanbul that becomes the capital of the Roman Empire,
uh,
that goes on for them.
Constantine also want it to stop all this feuding about what was Orthodox
Christianity.
So he uses the power of the emperor's throne to force bishops to come together
in several different councils.
The most famous of which in three 25
is the council of Nicea.
And of course this is where we get the term,
the nice seen creed,
which if you're Roman Catholic or Episcopalian or several other kinds of
Christianity,
you may recite the Nicene creed in on certain holy days are in church.
It's,
this is the longer creed,
which talks about Jesus being fully man,
fully human.
It brings in the trinity.
So you have trinitarian theology becoming a bit more solidified at the Council
of Nicea.
It didn't win the day because throughout the fourth century you still had fights
among different bishops.
Some people not accepting the Nicene creed.
Years later you had the cows,
the uh,
another creed,
uh,
pronounced at cal Seaton,
so that's called the Caledonian creed.
And all of these were attempts though,
promoted by the emperors.
See the emperors wanted to use Christianity to solidify a one empire again and
to keep it from being split.
And if you couldn't do that,
if you had different groups claiming to represent the right Christianity and
claimed everybody else represents the wrong Christianity.
So the real push for what counts as Orthodox Christianity and the bringing of
more unity to Christianity,
which we've not seen.
Right?
And this semester we've,
we've noted how you don't have what you would call a correct trinitarian
doctrine in the new testament.
It's just not there.
You've got all kinds of views about Jesus that would later be declared
heretical.
They're still there in the new testament.
And Chris,
what Christians do is we just read kind of carefully and interpret it slickly so
that,
you know,
it makes it look more orthodox than it actually is.
But that's because there was no orthodoxy that could claim to rule,
uh,
different Christians who call themselves Christians who have the empire.
This is what starts changing in the fourth century.
Like I said,
they don't succeed.
So you have debates about orthodoxy for centuries,
but it's with in the beginning of the fourth century and then his,
he had a long dynasty,
his,
uh,
his progeny,
his sons and their sons and their sons,
uh,
retain the throne,
four years after that.
And so you,
you had this constant Tinian dynasty that was able to bring a good bit of
solidity to the Roman Empire in the fourth century that it hadn't enjoyed in the
third century.
And therefore they use this to sort of bring about Orthodox Christianity as the
single form of Christianity.
That's the most important,
uh,
changed,
therefore for the fourth century.
But how do we get after that?
Of course,
as you know from your history,
uh,
the empire splits again and later you have the split between eastern
Christianity,
which is represented by those churches we call Orthodox located mainly as with
the Greek,
the,
the authority of the Greek Orthodox Church.
But of course you have Orthodox churches in each of the nations of the east.
So you have Russian orthodoxy,
Greek Orthodoxy and Syrian Orthodox Church.
You have different orthodox communities,
uh,
in the east and then Roman Catholicism in the West.
And that split of course is still with us.
That starts happening in later antiquity.
What,
but notice it's still not what anybody would call a world religion.
Now the very term world religion is something that has only come about in the
20th century.
And it was,
uh,
it was a term that was invented when Christians,
we're exploring around and seeing that there were other ways of being religious
and how do you want to categorize these things?
So around 1900,
some scholars invented this guy,
well,
there's world religion and then there are local religions.
You know,
African religion is not a world.
Religion is just a certain different kinds of paganism.
They thought,
uh,
and they thought,
well,
uh,
Judaism is not a world religion.
It's a religion of the Jews.
And by its very definition,
it's an ethnic religion.
Therefore it's not a religion that is any for anybody in the world.
That's why Jews don't go around missionizing and trying to convert everybody in
Asia to Judaism or everybody in Africa to Judaism.
But they said Christianity is different.
Christianity believed that it was the one true religion and therefore,
uh,
launched in the 19th century all these missionary activities.
And that was in the 19th century that you had a mainly Protestants in the 19th
century really trying to convert the whole world to Christianity and sending out
missions.
There's of course it started in the beginning in the 17th century with Roman
Catholics and in the,
uh,
North American South America trying to convert the Indians and trying to set up
colonies.
So the conversion of the Indians in North American,
South America,
mainly by Roman Catholics to Roman Catholicism,
and then later the the attempt in the 19th century by Protestant churches to
convert people all over the world.
It really does make Christianity start looking like a worldwide phenomenon,
but that's not really until the 19th century say that that happens before that
Christianity is basically the religion of Europe.
That's why Europeans still to this day,
even if they're not religious,
even if they don't consider themselves Christian,
they may consider that as completely atheistic,
but they see Christianity as part of the very fabric of European identity.
This is what's leading to the big debate about whether to admit Turkey into the
European Union.
There are a lot of people in Europe,
even good liberal people who are open minded and don't necessarily have anything
against Islam who don't want to have Turkey as part of Europe.
And one of the main reasons,
because it's not a Christian nation,
it doesn't have this.
And of course most of their nations aren't really Christian in the sense of
having the majority people observing Christianity,
but they still have this idea that what it means to be European is some
connection historically with Christianity.
And that's quite true because Christianity was not a world religion.
It existed in Europe until the modern period.
So,
but with the idea that there are other world religions that happens with
colonialism,
Christianity starts defining itself as a world religion.
So the first scholars who talked about this term said,
well,
there's only one world religion,
Christianity,
all the rest are local religions,
uh,
linked to some particular geographical area.
And then they start saying,
well,
okay,
wait a minute.
Buddhism kind of,
they kind of liked Buddhism.
They thought it kind of looked a bit like Protestantism.
So they said,
okay,
we'll let Buddhas and be a world religion also.
So for a while,
around 1900,
the two world religions recognize where Christianity and Buddhism.
And then gradually I started saying,
well,
maybe,
um,
maybe Islam is because it's actually not,
you don't have to be an Arab to be Muslim and you can see Muslims existing all
through Asia and that sort of thing in Africa.
Uh,
so maybe Islam is the third world religion and then kind of more for ideological
purposes,
they said,
well,
we'll let the Jews in,
you know,
so Judaism can be aware of religion also because you don't actually have to be
in one location to practice it.
Hinduism was a problem because the very word Hindu is a made up term for
religion because it just means Indian,
right?
This was just so Hinduism is a modern invention to a label to put over whatever
Indians in this,
whatever people in the subcontinent practice that relate something to something
that we would call God's,
we're going to call that Hinduism.
So Hinduism gets invented in the 20th century and then that gets to be another
world religion.
So then you get this ideology.
If you had to take a class in world religions or an introduction to religion and
say the year in 1980 you would have probably read a textbook that would probably
list as the undisputed world religions,
five Christianity,
Judaism,
Islam,
Hinduism,
Buddhism.
Now does Confucianism Count?
Well,
some textbooks and say,
yeah,
I wanna know does,
uh,
you know,
what do you paganism,
just,
you know what stuff that people just worship all kinds of gods of,
you know,
trees and rocks and things.
Well,
so,
but this,
the whole category of having world religions and having a list of them become
something that really is only developed in the academic study of religion in the
20th century.
So if someone asks you the question,
how did this little started by this Jewish Prophet in Galilee but went,
how did it become a world religion?
You really the honest,
most honest question and say,
well,
it didn't really happen until scholars invented it in the 20th century because
that's when the very category of world religion came about for us to use.
Of course,
if you wanted to say,
well,
when did you have start having Christians?
And are all over the world,
not just in Europe.
Well you'd have to say starting in the 17th century with the missions to north
and South America and then really in the 19th century with the,
with the missionaries,
especially from England and North America,
uh,
going to China and going to Japan and going to all over Africa.
So when you talk about when did this thing become a world religion?
Probably about the 19th century would be a good answer,
but that's counterintuitive to most of us.
Okay.
The last question I'm talking about is,
Nah,
we're out of time.
I was going to talk about why did Christianity grow before Constantine.
Obviously with Constantine,
you've get the emperor promoting this religion now and there are various
theories about what causes it to grow.
Before that,
some people have said because they for bad abortion are um,
and uh,
uh,
child and um,
birth control,
contraception.
Most early Christians seem to think that contraception was wrong and abortion
was wrong and putting out infants was wrong.
Some people will say,
well,
it's because they promoted the family.
I don't particularly buy that cause he got all these monks and nuns running
around to not reproducing.
Um,
some people even said,
well,
when Christians themselves right in this period about why they grow and why
people are flocking to this cause because we're better healers and exorcist,
we're better than Asclepius that healing people and exercising demons.
So Ramsey Macmullen,
retired historian right here at Yale has written famously about this,
that at patently enough,
second,
third century Christians were just really damn good healers and excesses.
And that may be why they grew,
uh,
itself.
So the question of why Christianity grew before then is a hot one that,
that a lot of historians or even right now debating.
Okay.
Any questions about that?
All right,
I'm gonna cut the lecture there because I want to pass out the final exams.
I think we've talked enough about in previous classes the difference between
historical interpretation and theological interpretation and modern
interpretation and postmodern interpretation.
That was what I was going to end up on.
But I believe we've covered that enough.
And you can always ask me questions about that later.
At some point if you like.
So let's pass the exams out please.
Yeah.
Any questions though,
why they're doing that?
This is your chance.
Yes sir.
Okay.
Why we think Rahm was persecuting Christians.
Where was your question?
What evidence do we have that they were doing it or why were they motivated to
do it?
Why were they,
why were they motivated to do it?
That's a very good question.
And when you realize that so much of the power of Rome was built on the ideology
of the emperor,
Romans really did believe they,
that they were the most pious nation on earth.
And one of the,
this is why whenever the Roman,
the Roman army went to another country,
they would always sacrifice to the local gods because they believed the local
gods protected them and cause growth.
So the Romans would sincerely believe that if you don't sacrifice to the gods,
if you don't,
if you're not a pious person,
the gods may punish you.
Well,
what happens then?
If you have a bunch of these Christians run around who refused to sacrifice to
the gods,
refuse to sacrifice to the emperor.
Not only is it a threat against the emperor himself,
it's a threat against all the people.
So in,
and it's also just a matter of patriotism.
What would happen to you right after nine 11 or even now if at a Yankees game
where when they said stand up and read and sing the Star spangled banner,
if you refuse to stand up,
you sat down,
you kept your baseball cap on your head and you started singing happy birthday.
Instead you're going to get beat up because the locals just won't like it.
Well,
that's the way it was a lot with early Christians.
It was the locals who felt like what they were doing was dangerous.
It tore against the social fabric of Roman society and it offended the gods.
So they had a lot of reasons to actually try to suppress Christianity.
Yes sir.
Do we know about Constantine converted?
He says,
because he saw a vision right before the battle.
Uh,
scholars debate that some scholars say he,
he converted because he looked around and he saw that this was,
although it was a minority movement,
there's no way that this has been a majority.
It was a vibrant movement that was going on in Rome and the Roman Empire.
And maybe he said that's something I can use.
He was already an admirer of the Sun God of the,
and he was moving toward a certain form of monotheism where the son was the only
God.
And so some people say it wasn't that big of a jump for him to switch that to
Jesus.
And so some people say he had this political idea that it was be a smart thing
to do,
and then he made up the vision later.
So there are different reasons we don't really know truly his psychological
motivations or conversion.
Okay.
Yes sir.
The question was,
what was the nature of persecution?
Was it really throwing Christians to the lions and that sort of thing?
Or was it more like destroying Christian texts?
It was different things at different times.
A lot of times it was crucifixion or killing people.
Torture to get people to confess.
Uh,
sometimes,
especially in the DC and persecution,
there was an attempt to get to force priests and bishops to turn over bibles and
Christian literature.
And in fact,
people could save their lives by giving up Christian books or Christian bibles
and they would be destroyed by the authorities.
So it took different forms like that,
and sometimes it was just less overt pressure.
You know,
you couldn't get promoted,
you couldn't do certain things.
Uh,
sometimes people would try to get you out of the Roman army if they found out
you were a Christian.
So that it took different forms.
Yes,
sir.
The institution of what?
The Papacy,
well,
it was originally simply,
uh,
he asked about the institution of the papacy.
It was originally simply the bishop of Rome.
But as you might imagine,
pretty early on,
Christianity in the third century,
bishops of the most important cities just became more important.
So the bishop of Jerusalem was important because Jerusalem was important.
The bishop of Alexandria was important because Alexander,
he brought the bishop of Constantinople was important because it was
Constantinople.
Likewise,
the Bishop of Rome was important and that was struggling among different major
bishoprics about which one would be,
uh,
leading.
It so happened that the bishop of Rome was still considered the center of the
earth for a long time.
And so gradually it just came that the bishop of Rome just sort of held
preeminence among all other bishops.
And it was informal that developed,
uh,
the real recognition of the Bishop of Rome as sort of the pope in way we think
of it that actually has to go into the middle ages before it starts developing.
And you don't,
for example,
you don't have papal infallibility declared as a doctrine until Michael,
the 19th century,
early 20th century.
So,
um,
I'll have to defer to Michael on Roman Catholic history because that's one of
his specialties.
But,
um,
so when we think of the Roman papers,
the papacy now as being sort of the infallible pope who,
who,
uh,
has his kind of has full say over everything that really is almost,
development that starts in more in the medieval period and comes into the modern
period.
So in the beginning it was just he was recognized as the head,
the sort of recognized,
uh,
more respected bishop.
All right,
let's talk about the finals.
You have two questions on your final and you get to choose option a and option
B.
I'm not going to read all of this.
You can talk to your section leaders,
email them,
talk to me,
email me if you have questions about this.
The things that I want to stress are a few things.
Don't go to the library.
If you need things like a concordance,
that's great.
It gives a concordance.
Use a Bible dictionary.
If there's something you just don't know the meaning of a word or a concept,
but don't go look up commentaries because already we've gotten papers from,
from some of you that it's clear that what you did was you went rent and read
some books and where in the library that told you about something in the New
Testament,
chances are it's bullshit because there's been more shit written about the Bible
than any other topic in the world for the last 2000 years.
And you probably,
even after taking this semester course,
you may not be able to tell the good stuff from the bad stuff.
So you don't need other scholarship to answer these questions.
These questions are designed so that you can use Bart Ehrman's textbook,
the tools we've shown you and the notes from class and just your own brain and
the primary texts you've been reading.
You can answer these questions yourself with what we've given you in class.
So that's one of the main things is don't try to go to the library to get
answers to these questions.
Use your brain.
Um,
I'm going to stress the length.
We always said eight pages,
but some of my teaching fellows have been complaining that,
uh,
y'all have creative ways of either stretching,
stretching our shrinking eight pages.
And so there's a word limit,
2,500 words.
So we're still looking for eight pages,
double spaced,
but not to exceed 2,500 words.
Use Your word counter on your software.
Now.
Uh,
the papers are due by five o'clock,
Monday,
April 27th.
You may email them,
uh,
as an attachment to your teaching fellow.
If the teaching fellow has given you permission to do that.
And I think they all did.
Um,
otherwise if you want to turn into hard copy,
please do so at the religious studies department and forth.
Did you on college street,
both of the questions addressed the kind of issues we raised all semester long,
so they shouldn't really be a surprise.
Several times we've talked about how to Christianity spread geographically and
when I gave the lecture on ax I explained how ax gives you a schematic outline
of the growth of Christianity.
So taking that one lecture,
uh,
on acts and the,
and the readings that you've done at that and then pull things from other
lectures and from other things in the semester.
Sort of thinking about,
well now what kind of Christianity would promote the sort of,
um,
uh,
letters of John,
what kind of Christianity would look different and use other of these writings
to say,
well,
I think maybe this kind of Christianity may have developed a bit differently.
You can focus on doctrinal issues,
you can focus on social structures or forms.
You can focus on ideologies.
And many of the issues that we raised up the semester,
it's your choice.
The main thing is,
oh,
just to show how Christianity did not develop in the smooth schematic way that
it's presented in the book of acts.
The second question,
I've given a couple of lectures where I stressed a whole lot more christology.
What Christology is,
uh,
the nature of Christ and how different early Christian documents 10 seem to be
working with different Christologies.
So what this question is to,
you've given three columns of text,
primary texts and it's,
it's a Chinese menu kind of thing.
Your suppose you have to choose at least one source from column a at least one
source from column B and at least one source from column c.
And you can use any others too.
You're not real,
you're not restricted to this,
but you have to use one of each of those,
uh,
sources in order to construct this answer of illustrating the diversity of
Christologies in early Christianity.
Any questions?
We do not accept or read late papers,
they just get a flat zero.
If you do need an extension,
ask for it ahead of time.
Not at five o'clock on Monday.
All right?
We will.
You're teaching fellows have the authority to work with me and grant you an
extension,
but you have to ask for it ahead of time,
but otherwise we expect those papers to be done by five o'clock Monday.
Okay.
[inaudible].